welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars tales of the Jedi all six episodes
of the first season this series
definitely caught me by surprise filling
in major arcs of the backstories of
Ahsoka Tano and Count Dooku yaddles so
many characters and by the way count
taku is kind of ahsoka's
great-great-grandmaster like dookuta
Qui-Gon Qui-Gon tan Obi-Wan Obi-Wan Todd
Anakin Anakin tadasoka and then uh well
I guess to extend that forward Ahsoka
kind of taught Luke it was implied and
Luke definitely taught grogu and grogu
teaches us all how to love but for real
though this series ties in with clone
wars and Phantom Menace the upcoming
Ahsoka series even answering some
questions about grogu during Order 66 so
let's break down all the Star Wars
Easter eggs that you might have missed
starting with episode 1 life and death a
title that also underscores The Duality
at the core of the series The Birth at
the bottom of that mentorship chain of
sokotano and the death of the paternal
top of it Dooku when his relationship
with the force completely severs now the
Fanfare at the start of every episode
includes red and blue lightsabers
reflecting off metallic faces we see
Grievous Bucket from resistance Chopper
Crosshair from bad batch a Commando
battle droid an imperial combat driver
then wrecker from bad batch then the
helmet of Pokemon and then Hunter for
bad batch and we open with the birth of
Ahsoka Tano on the planet Chile in 36
BBY that's ahsoka's reported birth date
based on the Clone Wars timeline prior
to this the earliest we had seen Ahsoka
was at the age of three in flashbacks
with plocoon the Jedi Master who abducts
uh recruits Ahsoka to the Jedi Order
maybe Ahsoka cries off-screen while her
father nakil calls to the others in the
togruda language of togridy
she's here
yeah Yakami soul and context probably
means she's boring or it's a girl but it
sounds like they worked in the term Soul
which in Spanish and other latin-based
languages translates to Sun so maybe
they took rootsie language May equate
childbirth with a sunrise he bows to the
Village Elder gantica who compared to
the others has his face with far more
texture and definition she looks like
the brush Strokes of a painting also has
adorned her clothes with animal bones
suggesting she's an experienced Hunter
who has taken many children on
ceremonial hunts over the years baby
Ahsoka only has four facial markings at
first took gruta's facial markings
change as they age like Ahsoka and Clone
Wars changes over the years when we see
her in Rebels and her markings were
different at age three when she met
placoon but a year later a bird lands on
the roof we see these blue birds later
in the forest but it reminds me of the
Mori bird who later in ahsoka's life
will accompany her representing the
spirit of the daughter these decorators
use droids and blasters knock ill here
uses one with an Astromech head as this
race was able to resist joining the
Republic for centuries gottica feeds a
few raccoon looking dogs with faces
resembling those of ads she anoints
Ahsoka in papti with paint for luck on
their hunt pop tea and Ahsoka hunt
kaibucks these are the herd animals
originally from kashyyk and legends
continuity the old Cartoon Network Star
Wars Clone Wars series but reintroducing
canon in the rise of Skywalker visual
dictionary Ahsoka takes in a squirrel
and all the fauna the forest showing a
bit of animal kinship that Jedi are
increasingly shown to have from Ezra
Bridger team in the fernok to grogu
taming the rancor in the book of Boba
Fett pop T gives Ahsoka two key lessons
about life and death look Asoka
everywhere there is life
value it
honor it you must face death a soccer do
not fear it yes value life face death
and to demonstrate that pop T where's
thehsoka not his backpack but as a Bjorn
on her chest so that the baby is right
up in there when the Kaiba gets stabbed
but Papi sends his saber tooth stalking
them and her nostril flares just a bit
showing how these two Curtis have their
own natural fight or flight instincts
while Ponte had told Ahsoka that she
would carry her home it's actually the
saber tooth who carries Ahsoka home
giving the togruden's a legend that they
would all tell each other for the years
and Market Ahsoka as a special one Jedi
Ahsoka is Jedi this whole idea of a lost
kid revealed to be beyond their ears is
a classic Universal archetypal Tale in
the New Testament young Jesus is left to
the temple and Mary and Joseph returned
to find him school and Scholars in the
Old Testament a lion attacks David but
David slays that lion with the might of
God and while the rest of this season is
darker and more cynical in its depiction
of the Star Wars Society I love that we
start here to be reminded of the natural
purity of the Force episode 2 Justice
opens with the Jedi T6 shuttle piloted
by a young Dooku voiced by Corey Burton
who also voiced CAD Bane in zero the
Hutt and young Qui-Gon Jinn designed to
look like a younger Liam Neeson and
absolute snack he's voiced by Mikhail
Richardson Liam Neeson's real life son
while it's not hard to recognize these
characters note that they are never
actually named until the final exchange
of the episode there are much wise a man
and I qui-gonjin
thanks to your teachings and Dooku's
name has never even said in the episode
through the uninitiated this story does
work as a universal tale of a Jedi
master tempted by Darkness if you didn't
know who this character was you'd just
be like oh a Jedi who I might get along
with oh wait he's a horrible villain
he's really not that horrible I mean
compared to all the other dirt bags in
this story they land in his burnt out
clearing watched over by Thin birds that
look like variants of the steelpackers
from Force awakens and Andor the Loader
Droid struggles with one last stack for
that tow cart in contrast with the Droid
in episode 5 who was in its prime
showing how this land has been truly
scoured for the last of its resources
and there's such great animation detail
in this rotting Town mud puddles flies
everywhere that poor dog with the ribs
showing the Silhouettes and the windows
include narcona and erodion and of
course the woman with that dog will
later be the one who starving for food
brings the senator to them the bar tanks
are like the ones in the Monza Isley
Cantina which the lucasfilm team would
later repurpose as the heads of the IG
assassin droids the Elder woman is
voiced by Vanessa Marshall who voices
Harrison Doula in Rebels
allow me to make my intentions clear
s similar to Christopher Lee's gestures
and attack the clones and his lightsaber
though blue-bladed will later see has
the same curved Hilt as his red saber
later will and qui-gon's lightsaber is
the same green one that he wields in
Phantom Menace based on qui-gon's age
though this is likely the earliest we
have seen in Star Wars Canon on screen
because this would be a few decades
before Phantom Menace and I like how
this episode shows that with the
townspeople's clothes looking like Old
World European I don't think we've
really seen this wardrobe design in Star
Wars before Senator dagane's son is
voiced by Josh Keaton who voiced skinny
Steve in Marvel's what if he's guarded
by two-ton a binary lifter Droid and
this sun like Clark Griswold's boss's
wife and Christmas vacation sympathizes
with the kidnappers these kidnappers
look at hungry enough to actually want a
subscription to the Jelly of the month
club Senator dagonay is voiced by Mark
Rolston longtime actor from Shawshank
Redemption and aliens actually another
shotshank after longtime voice actor
Clancy Brown voices the sixth brother in
the final episode the center has with
him an ra7 protocol Droid and he and his
soldiers dressed in blue and gold binary
kind of looking like those goofy Swiss
guard outfits the senator says you serve
the Senate no
we serve the people of this Republic so
Dooku as a Jedi came from a wealthy
family and he's actually retained a
relationship with a sister which you
know Jedi are not supposed to do so he's
always been more of a rule breaker an
idealist following his own code he
ignites his lightsaber down and to the
side and as he repels the blast he once
again uses the wide flourish as a form
two lightsaber combat this is the one
more akin to fencing the light on
Dooku's face is really well done this
episode from the table light in the
tavern and now with the lightsaber glow
it moves from one side of his face to
the other reflecting his shifting
resolve as he decides to force choke the
senator and Kevin keiner's music and the
sound design is just so excellent here
and throughout the series corruption
like yours must be eradicated no
stop
master
it's over
what we thought was a gusting wind was
actually the sound of the dark side of
the forest coursing through Dooku
finally silenced when he releases his
grip they leave behind some forces to
help the villagers and one of those
soldiers Pets the rib dog all Dooku
tells Qui-Gon that he's a much wiser man
than he is which is something Qui-Gon
will later tell his Apprentice in
Phantom Menace you've been a good
Apprentice of being one
and you're a much wiser man than I am
episode 3 choices follows Dooku and Mace
Windu TC Carson returning to voice the
role from Clone Wars they're headed to
raxis secundus to retrieve the body of
Jedi Master Cattery the screen shows
that she's a moralian race like luminar
and Julie and the orabesh reads Master
katri now raxxas secundus showed up in
Clone Wars bad batch during the Clone
Wars this will join the separatists we
actually see that anti-republic
sentiment here they're greeted by Hennel
who has a scar across his lips and later
snarls you and all of the scented
puppets will still recognition this is
voice actor Andrew Casino who voices saw
Guerrera in Clone Wars and bad batch saw
also shows up in bad batch and Rebels
with the scar across his face as they
chat with Senator Larrick hannel and
samaj stand behind them flowering at
lyric to make sure he plays along handle
even turns his head just a little bit
when Dooku suggests wanting to see where
katri died Dooku and Windu since
something is off and Windu wants to take
it back to the council but Duke is like
uh-oh we're gonna investigate this alone
you notice the burn marks and lightsaber
slashes on the trees but nothing on the
ships this leads to a shootout with the
guard and some Rex's battle droids samaj
explains how lyric liked the senator
dagonet was corruptly putting his own
personal interests ahead of his people
each of these episodes really shows how
Dooku adopts separatist philosophy Jedi
are lap dogs of the Senate the bidding
always comes first it's evident
throughout the Galaxy Jedi claim peace
but mostly keep Law and Order for the
rich and Powerful Laden's episode you
could tell so much that his ideology has
points and to not lose heart and he asks
Windu who do you think the Jedi would
truly keep peace if they continued to
take everything the Senate says as law
back on Coruscant they bury katri the
casket lowers into the floor and then
shoots up in a beam of light like a
lightsaber I'm guessing it's being
incinerated and just releases this
blinding light as a result of the fire
we see Yoda plokun Chiari Mundi Jocasta
new outside later Stacy tin and Tara
sanube the mentor Jedi whose corpse
tragically ends up in The Fortress
inquisitorious in the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series Dooku learns Windu is being
offered receipt on the High Council and
asked if he knew before they went to
raxxas we see how his ego is stung as
his Ambitions are being slighted on to
episode 4 the Sith Lord Dooku's beard
it's now a bit grayer because this is
several years later he slips into the
back room at the Jedi Temple archives
and accesses the file using saifo Diaz's
access code to erase the listing for
kamino this fills in what Obi-Wan
investigates and attack the Clones
Camino being erased from the archived
star Maps sifo Diaz was a friend of
dookus who had a premonition of a Great
War and secretly commissions a clone
army that Darth Sidious will later seize
control of by having Dooku use the Pikes
to kill off sipo DS Dooku greets Jocasta
new who spoke of Dooku in a deleted
scene from Attack of the Clones here she
mentions qui-gon's running with a Sith
on Tatooine placing this episode in the
middle of phantom menace when Qui-Gon
and Obi-Wan bring Anakin to the Jedi
Temple Qui-Gon chats with yaddle who at
this point was part of the Jedi High
Council but was not present at the end
of phantom menace at qui-gon's funeral
on Naboo they say I guess water travels
fast wow all statements did counsel will
rather
surprising Qui-Gon is now voiced by Liam
Neeson himself who also cameo in the
final scene of Obi-Wan Kenobi I would
not be surprised if lucasfilm was like
hey uh while you're here in the green
screen could you get coming over here in
audiobook and recruit some lines thanks
meanwhile yaddle is voiced by Bryce
Dallas Howard who has directed a lot of
better episodes of the Mandalorian and
the book above a pet this is the first
time we've heard yaddle speak and she
does not invert her syntax the way Yoda
does showing that his speech isn't
really a product of his race but just
rather unique to him now there are times
when I'm up so late that it Cycles back
to early and I just have a hard time
sleeping with Rosy finger Dawn creeping
into my bedroom it used to be the case
that when that would happen I would grab
a blue blocks blackout sleep mask but
now blue blocks has become Bon charge so
I grab a bond charge sleep mask instead
I know it sounds weird to say I'm bad at
sleeping but I am I don't know maybe I
have thin eyelids or something but if
I'm using Von charges sleep mask that
doesn't matter it blocks out 100 of
incoming light and it's very soft and
has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for people sleeping on their belly
side and on their back it is super
comfortable and I can confirm that I can
see absolutely nothing if you're making
silly faces at me I wouldn't know I'm
just gonna take a quick nap right now in
a back Bond charge ships worldwide and
have other great products like low blue
light bulbs red light therapy devices
and blue light glasses go to
pawncharge.com
star is a news coupon code new rockstars
to save 20 percent that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e.com Slash new
rockstars and use a coupon code new
rockstars to save twenty percent Dooku
warns Qui-Gon about the Sith Lord saying
that he won't be there to protect him
and indeed Maul will be the end of
Qui-Gon Qui-Gon complements Obi-Wan and
Dooku says that he'd like to meet
Obi-Wan someday indeed they will meet an
attack of the Clones and how now this
interaction here is at Sunset which in
Phantom Menace is when Qui-Gon Adobe on
chat on the Terrace and High Council
including the adult test Anakin by
himself so Qui-Gon must be on his way up
to chat with Obi-Wan and yaddle is on
her way to test Anakin it's fun to think
of the day Obi-Wan brought Anakin into
the temple is a day that Dooku erased
kamino from the archives Dooku says they
grow up so fast
our students yes it is the way of things
yes this parallels Yoda's amazing line
to Luke in The Last Jedi we are what
they grow Beyond later after the final
battle of Panama's Dooku Mourns Qui-Gon
at the great horse tree in the Jedi
Temple Courtyard this location has shown
up in Clone Wars the tree's leaves are
dying symbolized in all these characters
being in the Twilight of the Jedi's
dominance and this tree is a very very
big deal Palpatine destroys most of the
Jedi relics when he takes over the
temple but he keeps two Twigs of this
tree the story of shattered Empire
explores how Luke Skywalker recovers
these and keeps one of them but he gives
the other to Lieutenant Shara Bay and
her husband kesdamarin they plan it
outside of their home on Yavin 4 and
their son is poe Dameron who plays on
that Force tree as a kid and nearly
Burns it down now this did lead to some
theories in the sequel Trilogy era that
Poe might be Force sensitive and that's
why he's such a good pilot it's probably
not the case but the force might have
guided him to meet the right people and
I like to think the tree might have had
something to do with it yaddle says the
council is leaving for
the funeral is to be held there and
since she follows Dooku she never makes
it to the funeral explaining why she
wasn't there for the funeral in Phantom
Menace they both head out to the
industrial regions of Coruscant where
Dooku met with Sidious an attack of the
Clones and here Dooku in City's debate
you've gone too far
I don't know what you mean yep that is
Ian McDormand coming back to voice
Sidious here and in the background we
hear this Opera soprano recalling the
opera house where Palpatine told Anakin
the tragedy of doth plague is the wise
we learned that Dooku wanted Qui-Gon as
a potential ally referring to qui-gon's
fixation on the living Force his
Defiance of the High Council Dooku
really thought he could flip Qui-Gon
which is super interesting but Sidious
saw Qui-Gon as only a potential ally to
Dooku showing how Sidious is grounded in
the Sith rule of two he never trusts his
Apprentice to take on another Apprentice
because then those two could gang up on
him and replace him Dooku's offended by
this you question my loyalty
always guess it is a sith's nature to
always be distrustful of his Apprentice
yaddle confronts them and tries to turn
Dooku against Sidious I'm afraid
I know you are I'm afraid it is too late
and the saber glow again shifts from one
side of Dooku's face to the other this
moment also parallels Han Solo and force
awakens it's true
no it's not leave here with me come home
I miss you I'm being torn apart I Want
to Be Free of this pain I know what I
have to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do it
just when you think they're gonna come
back to the light you realize the true
struggle they're having is with stifling
the last of the goodness inside of them
their dual mirrors Yoda and Dooku's duel
and attack the Clones yaddle using
similar flips and leaps Dooku closes the
gate on her which lowers like the teeth
of a gaping mouth City it's his mouth
smiling at her devouring all the Jedi
Sidious thinking he's Triumph it says
Rise
my friend just like Sidious will say the
Anakin after Anakin proves his loyalty
by turning on a Jedi in that case Mace
Windu right
Seattle's the one who Rises she Rises
the gate and we hear John Williams
sports theme and remember before she was
able to survive by squeezing into the
gap between the teeth just giving her a
little bit more room to work with and
when light floods into the room
Palpatine covers his face because just
in case Seattle's able to survive this
or jump away to safety he had just been
closer to the light and exposed his full
face and he does not want her to see his
identity and connect that Palpatine
Insidious are the same person and then
the final tragic exchange I want only to
bring peace and hold to the Galaxy
already so many absolutely for what you
call
order
then
let me give you peace Master
yeah you can really hear that God
real face in Corey Burton's voice on the
word peace channeling the cold
bloodedness that we hear in cadbane and
yes Yale's death here does remove her
from possibility is a possible rescuer
of grogu from the Jedi Temple during
order 66. she may have known his
existence but she was not the one who
got him out of the temple on to episode
5 practice makes perfect Anakin watches
Ahsoka train in the Jedi Temple with
some remote droids Yoda is there Mace
Windu placun Obi-Wan and then over on
the other side deepavalaba and her
princess Caleb Doom now Ahsoka is being
trained by Tara sanube hum Ahsoka meets
in the Clone Wars season 2 episode
lightsaber lost I think this is taking
place after that maybe a year and a half
into the war because notice ahsoka's
outfit is a mix between her tube top
from the Clone Wars movie there's the
end of season two she doesn't have the
tube top here but she still has her
white leggings from that era so she's
kind of in between the costume redesign
and that's why she's only using one
lightsaber still here however Obi-Wan's
hair is back to being long as it was
during the attack of the Clones movie
even though it should be shorter from
this era of the Clone Wars animated
series Caleb Marvels at ahsoka's moves
even though these two characters seem to
meet for the first time in Rebels but
who knows this kid went through a lot of
trauma probably saw like dozens of
skilled Jedi at the temple but Anakin
thinks his test is a bunch of [ __ ]
so he takes her to a real test with
Captain Rex having grown clone troopers
stun a teenager over and over but hey it
ends up helping her in order 66 so I
guess abusive teaching is worth it one
two three four one two three four one
two three rushing or dragging so you do
know the difference Captain Rex and the
other clone troopers include
use the blue blast stunt setting that we
saw used on Leia in A New Hope I like
how ahsoka's confidence actually helps
her at first in the first round she
senses the first shooter and repels
several blasts until getting tagged
eventually on the fifth one but round
after round she actually gets worse at
it the second time they get her in three
blasts then two the next time and her
eyelids hang lower and lower the next
time it's just too quick blasts and then
the entity makes it seem like it's one
after that but then she gets this pep
talk from Anakin I want it to be
difficult this
is about life and death ah life and
death the title of episode 1 returning
thehsoka to her original lessons of
Natural Balance and notice how this
round she crushes it so we jump ahead
several years to a different base well
into the Clone Wars ahsoka's white
leggings are gone she's now just wearing
the full redesign outfit from season
three onward and she now has her second
lightsaber that she started using at
that point the five of bursts have all
now painted their armor blue it seems
like Ahsoka has scheduled these sessions
on her own now she successfully repels
and stuns she does a mid-air roll just
as she did with the training remote
droids earlier showing she is just as
strong against clone troopers as she is
against battle droids so we end this
episode in this fascinating place on the
same ship in the final episode of Clone
Wars this tiny little moment after
Ahsoka has removed Rex's chip and this
is when Rex was pretending to still be
under Order 66 brainwash so we could
have scored Ahsoka as a prisoner in
front of the other clone troopers before
they turn on them and escape and in this
little moment Rex says let's hope all
that training pays off yeah we did not
hear this in Clone Wars finale episode
but there wasn't enough time for them to
say it and I love how deep learning
keeps doing this keeps looping back and
back and back on the events of Order 66
to just fit in these little Grace notes
for each of these characters and in this
case this episode suggests that the
skills Ahsoka used to escape Order 66
were initially inspired by Anakin who is
now ironically the tip of the order 66
spear but this is a truly a skill
continued and mastered without Anakin's
Guidance just Ahsoka and Rex working
together sessions continued by her own
individual discipline and then on to the
final episode episode 6 resolve we see
padme's funeral on Naboo which was shown
during the epilogue of Revenge of the
Sith in the crowd we see bail Organa and
Mon mothma and Bale Seas across the way
Ahsoka Ahsoka what are you thinking why
are you showing up here I get it you
want a more Padme but it was really
stupid to go here now this is actually
an alteration from ahsoka's timeline in
the Ahsoka novel by EK Johnstone which
does not really have bail in Ahsoka
meeting each other until much later but
Dave filoni said that he based this
episode on the same general outline that
he put together for the Ahsoka novel and
his mind they're roughly the same story
even if some of the details are
different I guess I agree this is just a
condensed version of the novel The Novel
is really good I would have enjoyed
having bit more time living in that era
of ahsoka's life rather than just like
14 minutes Bale tells Ahsoka there's
nothing you could have done
for either of them he's referring to
both Padme and Anakin Anakin whom Ahsoka
at this point assumes died in order 66.
it's not until Rebels she realized that
Anakin Vader are the same person bail
leaves Ahsoka Khan link and gives Ahsoka
some double speak to contact him if she
ever needs anything and a big mistake to
say this to the clone troopers because
now you know they're gonna hit him up
for like concert tickets and [ __ ] Ahsoka
and Rex leaving a BTL S3 y-wing
Starfighter the precursor to the white
wing in the later era we catch up with
Ahsoka on a farm Planet which is not
specifically Rada but it seems to be
like roughly based on it she goes by the
name ashla as she does in the novel
Ashley is the name of a lot of things in
Star Wars is the name of a moon of
tython Ashland is also a name given to
the light side of the force but she
might have actually chosen it because
there was another togruda girl in the
Jedi Temple named ashla during the time
of attack of the Clones the farmers
worry about not being able to keep up
with Imperial quotas but this jerk kid
Praises Palpatine Emperor Palpatine
brought peace it's a lot like the
Senators and Andor who compliment
Palpatine for protecting them and saying
what he means ahsoka's Force sensitivity
is exposed and so when she returns to
the Village she finds the Inquisitor the
sixth brother waiting for them having
torched a place the sixth brother I
mentioned this guy a few times my
Obi-Wan Kenobi breakdowns he's the one
who binds Ahsoka in the novel and here
he looks incredible he's got this
awesome mask he is hooded he's got a
cloak with the Imperial Crest on it how
do we have had at least one of the
inquisitors and there'll be one Kenobi
series look like this now the kyber
crystals of his twin blades are going to
be the kyber crystals that Ahsoka turns
into her twin white blades and Rebels
and a Mandalorian Ahsoka saves the kid
not by moving the sixth brother but by
throwing the kid out of the way God
imagine she took some satisfaction
tossing him aside and like great Samurai
films this duel is short but perfect
just three to four swings that Ahsoka
grabs the hill kicks the sixth brother
and finishes him off there's way more
build up than actual dueling and it's
far more effective that way kind of like
that final short duel and Kill Bill
volume one but really this reminds me of
when Maul finds Obi-Wan on Tatooine and
Rebels their Final Duel remember how
short that was just a few Swift moves
and the fight is over and that's all you
really need in fact that's how long it
would be for Ahsoka here this is the
same Asoka who already held her own
against freaking Maul on Mandalore in
the Clone Wars final season inquisitors
remember are trained by Vader and not
the best of Vader they're trained by
Vader's abuse whereas Ahsoka was trained
by the best of Anakin all of Anakin's
empathy and I guess a bit of Anakin's
abuse again again again
I love this series so much I can't
believe how much lore and deeper meaning
they're able to pack into all of this
you can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye foreign
[Music]